foreign
[Music]
hey Chuck I got another explainer for
you all right so so I want to talk about
Stonehenge okay I've never we haven't we
don't have an explainer on Stonehenge
and the reason why it's like in my head
but first it's kind of always in my head
because of Manhattan hinge uh but it's
in my head especially this time around
because I don't know if you knew this
but much of the staff of Star Talk was
invited to go to London to do a star
talk
show in front of an audience at a
conference sponsored by Privateer and
Omega watches and that conference was
all about space sustainability I know
you're a sustainability guy I don't know
if you ever thought about it with regard
to space of course yeah I mean but
because space it's like if you put up
too many satellites is that sustainable
right you know is there room for another
satellite and what are you doing to the
astronomers who want to look up at night
all right so and it just happened to
coincide just happened to coincide with
the summer solstice nice we were there
on
June 21st and it occurred to me like at
the end of the day and I'm saying wait a
minute we just did this and it's this is
the solstices today wait a minute wait
wait we're driving distance from
Stonehenge oh my gosh and so so so
Privateer it was and Omega were kind
enough to like try to robust for us on
the spot right we had to get a driver
get you know pull him out of whatever he
was doing because it was very
spontaneous and we drove out there in
the middle of the night to watch the
sunrise over Stonehenge now I am
unfamiliar with this company Privateer
and I am also uh curious as to why they
did not invite Chuck Nice on this trip
I'll answer the first question only okay
no uh Steve Wozniak who we we have a
guest on StarTalk recently I know Steve
it's a pet project of his and he's
invited some other folks who care about
the future of space Steve Wozniak one of
the co-founders co-founders of apple
back in the day that he's he's the guy
that you see next to jobs when they're
sitting with the tiny little computer
like in somebody's basement or garage
basement
it's the laws that's sitting next at the
standing next to uh to Stephen right the
two of them together right yeah was
wired all the circuit boards it wasn't
that's right yeah Steve Jobs Steve Jobs
had the ideas was right made this stuff
happen made it happen so so anyway so as
in terms of a guy who makes stuff happen
he cares about the future sustainability
of space so anyway so that's why we were
there cool in London and we took this
jaunt out we had half our staff they
have to start talk staff with us out to
Stonehenge and in the middle of the
night
spontaneously decided to do that and so
no it was fun and in fact we took video
just visiting you know big band and the
bridges and and Stonehenge and uh we're
gonna post that pretty soon so look for
that yeah I'm going to tell you the
truth I'm I'm just going to go ahead and
and put it out there
I don't know what Stonehenge is
I don't understand what the hype is on
the one hand they're telling me that
it's some kind of alien crap on the
other hand it's uh some some way of the
uh these ancient uh Druids who's were
able to look at the constellations and
decipher things through these big you
know Stones Some say it's a religious
thing I gave up on Stonehenge so long
ago because I've heard so many things
okay I went on an expedition and the
Expedition head his name was Gerald
Hawkins and he wrote a book called
Stonehenge decoded which came out was in
the late 60s early 70s where he was one
of the first if not the first to
identify it as an astronomical
Observatory rather than simply a
religious
get you know a an occasion for religious
gatherings of ancient peoples okay and
so he was our Expedition head we took a
visit to Stonehenge itself and then we
went on to the Uncharted Stones up in
Scotland in a little near a little town
called killed Martin killed Martin
Scotland I have a friend Laurie
kilmartin oh yeah yeah so there are
Stones there in in some Farmers field
and we were there uh I was there in the
astronomical team we had excavators we
had um uh anthropologists and we had
archaeologists and so all of us were
there analyzing these stones and so it
sensitized me it was a baptism into the
fact that ancient peoples
cared about the sky on a level that
maybe most people would not give them
credit for doing
and so
Stonehenge had long been associated with
the work of The Druids but carbon dating
and other sort of uh methods and tools
to figure out when the stones arrived
there and were erected has it pre-date
The Druids by upwards of a thousand
years I could not have it could not have
been The Druids all right that does not
mean The Druids didn't fully embrace
the existence of Stonehenge well it was
kind of hard not to they're Giants
somebody else built it use it right yeah
right yeah totally take advantage of it
in whatever way you might feel the need
and so Stonehenge is a set of circles of
huge Stones I mean these things are way
bigger than a human being so human being
stacked two or three times high and
these Stones weigh multiple tons it's
it's made out it's called Blue Stone
that is not available in the area where
Stonehenge was erected oh look at that
so we don't need the finest blue stone
reported from Italy indeed
you thought Italian marble was something
to wonder oh no my friend it's all about
the blue stone now
so these are these are blue stones and
they came from miles away okay and so
the question was why would anyone do
this and what was it about what
motivated them what was driving them and
the most obvious thing if you look at it
for the whole year and map it out I got
it is that there is an alignment of
What's called the heel stone this is a
stone that sits well outside the circle
of stones and if you look through an
opening in the stones at the heelstone
on the morning of the summer the summer
solstice
the sun rises exactly over the heelstone
oh wow so it's a very astronomical
moment for this thing and you if whether
or not you say it's a religious
it's a religious Monument
what you can say is if it is religious
that religion cared about the summer
solstice the solstice okay all right so
there it is so the summer solstice is
the summer solstice whether or not you
layer religious belief systems on top of
it yeah I mean well yeah what Gerald
Hawkins further did was he noted that
there were these holes dug in the ground
56 of them outside the perimeter of the
outer rim of stones but these are
vertical Stones they're called men
here's and the and and it it's the hinge
when I think of it these vertical
structures Made of Stone Stonehenge when
I got to Manhattan we have vertical
structures that are buildings okay steel
and and glasses okay so then I didn't
want to call it building hinge that
wasn't local enough so that's what I
called it Manhattan hinge took a photo
of it and then published that in 2002
and then since then I'm delighted to
announce that tens of thousands of
people flood the streets for the two
days of the year where this alignment of
the in this case the Setting Sun aligns
with the street grid has nothing to do
with the solstice because when they
light out the street grid of Manhattan
they weren't thinking climate or I mean
a time of the year or anything it
doesn't want to do what fit to the
geometry of Manhattan Island which is
long and skinny right so that's all they
did which means when that aligns as it's
some other day not the solstice the New
York Times tried to call it the the the
Manhattan Solstice it's like no yeah
it's nothing to do with this
right okay just like stay in your lane
just I got this okay right so I'm just
delighted to announce that tens of
thousands of people flood the streets
for reasons other than Con Ed digging
holes okay now by the way people uh
those of you listening uh you just found
out that Neil deGrasse Tyson and is
single-handedly responsible for hundreds
of people every year getting hit by a
car
which is I went to the went to this
department I said you know why don't we
organize this and block off the streets
yo we need authorization from the
mayor's office it's like it's going to
happen anyway yeah it's not like people
are going to flood the streets only with
your permission they're doing it
anyway so I'm alerting you of this and
so I got to run around very disappointed
maybe by now they're going to figure it
out but anyway back to Stonehenge so
there are these 56 circles that surround
the stones and Gerald Hawkins
in the early days of scientific
Computing put these coordinates into his
computer and he found that there's a
configuration of these circles that
enable you to predict eclipses
eclipses
recur on what's called a Saros time
scale and aceros is the time it takes
the Sun and the Moon
to realign in a configuration that would
give you another eclipse
because the moons orbit around the Earth
is tipped relative to Earth's orbit
around the Sun what that means is
you don't get a lunar eclipse every full
moon and a solar eclipse every new moon
if that was all lined up you get
eclipses twice a month right but we only
get them every couple of you know every
two and a half years or so and so so
it's only when that geometry lines up
and the the the there are families of
eclipses that repeat every 18.6 years
and it's called the lunar Saros that's
wow okay so now watch what happens if
you take 18.6 and multiply it by three
mm-hmm
you get 56 holes you get to 56. so he
viewed these holes as a as a mechanism
to get some handle on the prediction of
eclipses which would have granted these
ancient peoples some understanding of
the Motions of the heavenly bodies that
no one would ever give them credit for
absolutely okay later decades later
there's been some re-questioning as to
whether this was actually an eclipse
predictor but no one is questioning the
alignment on the Hillstone of the summer
solstice anyhow it's still there it's a
national monument it's protected it's
still in the middle of a of a of a farm
field
um but everybody is in agreement and
there are tours that go there you can't
touch the stones anymore when I was
there you could climb on the stones
that's how old I am nice
that's kind of cool back in my day we
didn't give a damn about Stonehenge
wow we climbed all over it we sat there
we drank beer on it some people actually
made love on it it was wonderful they
caught my initials
on hand
the all old men on the porch sound like
that
Roxanne and actually go to Stonehenge
and put your name in it ah man those
were the days
oh by the way by the way there are
people who don't believe or recognize
that ancient peoples
had the same brains as we do I mean
they're they're human beings they can be
as clever or as stupid uh it's they just
had less technology so you can ask how
long does it take to find Bluestone and
drag it you know dozens of miles to a
location it takes long if you don't have
tractors and and trucks and but it
doesn't take forever no okay and so they
they knew about the wheel you could roll
on on logs logs and ropes and things so
this is not an impossible thing to
imagine but people who do find it hard
to imagine
they're quick to say what Chuck
um
that it was aliens
aliens yeah so here's my
and we're going to end with this comment
about aliens okay
just because you can't figure out how
ancient peoples did it
doesn't mean aliens help them
all right this has been yet another star
talk explainer this one on Stonehenge
and Manhattan hens and The Druids and
all of the above and not aliens Chuck it
was good to have you here oh it was a
pleasure all right Neil deGrasse Tyson
four-star talk as always keep looking up
foreign
[Music]